julien aux pommes d'amour parce que
c'est pas secret vous avez rencontré kad
merad votre compagnon sur le plateau de
c'est à vous en 2014
vous animez les missions de manière très
occasionnel puisqu'on est ensemble après
midi rappelez vous tout est fait on
avait visionné un film ensemble on est à
côté au cinéma et tu m'as dit si
celui-ci s'était je me souviens très
bien c'était super condrieu et tu m'as
dit c'est ma première ce soir enfin je
remplace ce soir anne cécile est
exactement et tu m'as dit ouais je
t'avais dit tu vas est exceptionnel tout
ça et le coup de foudre s'est passé sur
cette émission qu'on aime beaucoup
d'ailleurs c'est à vous et regardez
en fait tu sais pas s'il est mal à
l'aise s'il veut vous draguer ou quoi
mais il essaye de vous faire rire et ça
marche
regarde rebelles avec un duo à trois
c'est intrigant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
énormément avec je trouve ce dernier qui
est plus talentueux que je connaisse
même en impro et tous et le plus drôle
vraiment c'est ici il est exceptionnel
mais c'est beau parce qu'on aimerait
tous avoir des images de la première
fois on a rencontré notre moitié vrai
avoue c'était une erreur
j'étais chez mireille de tunis moi c'est
ça elle nageait en chanson au toit c'est
là il ya du tout qui est tombé ce sont
escarpins et là maintenant je la regarde
et il a il a juste repris la miettes de
thon comme ça ils se sont regardés
il manie juin dans là c'est vrai alors
c'est bon c'est pas le premier coup de
foudre
franchement est-ce que vous avez vu
comment ça s'est vu le premier coup de
foudre non mais beaucoup de foot pendant
l'émission après franchement alors pour
tout vous dire c'était la première fois
que je présentais une émission en direct
dont elle était extrêmement stressé
ouais ça ça vous vend plus
non mais j'avais peur de ne pas y
arriver et je j'étais très concentré je
n'ai pas vu ce qui se passait vraiment à
mener pour l'instant là vous l'avez pas
encore vue après voilà vous avez alors
parce que je vous le dis on a un extrait
aussi de quatre plus récentes et sur rtl
et part de votre rencontre et ils ne
sont pas super à l'aise à un cadre mais
si elle parce qu'il est très pudique
alors là on n'est pas obligé de le voir
cet extrait du goulet nouvelle voit on
pas à moi ça ne me dérange pas mais
c'est vrai que vous êtes rencontrés son
plateau de c'est à vous alors qu'elle
remplace anne sophie lapix en 2015 en
tout cas c'est la première vue la
première fois je l' ai vu c'est la rue
89 et pour une fois je les jeux d
approcher physiquement c'est là je
dirais pas après comment ça s'est passé
il a bien sûr c'est ce jour là anne
sophie lapix et remplacé par julia
vignali l'a dit que j'avais aperçu il
est joli aperçu
je l'avais aperçu mais pas vraiment bref
je commençais par ben bernanke
c'est normal c'est la limite et 2 et
puis non mais pas forcément en avant
cette histoire comme les gens sont au
courant depuis pas forcément tous
d'ailleurs
j'ai même passé mes parents le seul
salut des très belles histoires
heureusement qu'ils sont passe à la télé
des coups de foudre à la télé on vous a
fait un top 3 des coups de foudre a été
le numéro trois c'est alizé grégoire
lyonnet qui étaient partenaires dans
danse avec les stars en 2013 et qui sont
ensuite mariés en 2016 c'est beau alors
dans le premier extrait on voit alizé
danse avec grégoire sont pas en couple
mais on sent qu'il ya un truc
franchement c'est vrai qu'on sent on
s'en aille chez moi j'ai vu direct
lorsqu'il est comme ça chez moi je
regardais j'ai dit ça c'est fait bîmes a
tenu à hilal pis regarde
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais quand même là c'est vrai que
j'étais peut-être pas le seul à m'en
doutais 1
là c'est vrai que là quand même ça l
était pas complètement wii est le
deuxième extrait se passe pendant les
répétitions du prime et là on sent que
grégoire il a passé la seconde
regardez ils draguent ouvertement alizés
en lui demandant d'être plus proche de
lui et là je me suis dit on peut la
faire à tout le monde sauf à ramous
dallas jeudi à la trappe le visage
compte rapprocher d'eux - claque tu
t'arrêtes dans le mouvement tu vois tu
es encore trop sage là pour coup le truc
c'est que il faut que tu saches à lèvres
ok je remercie un cadeau ou presque
l'idée c'est que tu mets ton rouge à
lèvres et que quand tu vas te rapprocher
mois visuellement on voit que tu t'es
vraiment un piment c'est à dire j'aime
pas ta victoire et donc la clac clac
clac coup
wen
un autre couple qui s'est découvert à
télé qu ici sur le plateau ce n'est pas
qu'ils s'étaient connus sur le plateau
laurent delahousse et alice taglioni
c'est en bus pendant jt de france 2 et
depuis ils ont une petite fille ensemble
j'avais oublié ça regardez leur
rencontre soir merci d'être avec nous
alors après plusieurs films d'action
vous retrouver là la comédie c'est dur
en france de trouver la bonne comédie le
bon scénario
oui oui c'est dire finalement vous vous
commencez à l'aîné ce métier parce qu'au
départ vous aviez plus tôt on va dire
des doutes actrice c'est bien ben y
avait le piano quand vous étiez jeune
vous commencez à l'aimer ce métier je
commence à assumer
l'idée d'être actrice pose est est-ce
qu'un jour à l'iss devant un public en
concert c'est quelque chose
d'envisageable ou pas du tout avec
plaisir et j'espère venir vous en parler
d'accord ça c'est une info
[Applaudissements]